you look fantastic there's something
different about you I can't I can't put
my finger on it I don't know what it is
you know I started to do a little color
on my beard oh you put a little hold on
the beer you know what it was getting
great you know I'll be 50 this year
[Applause]
amazing shape I like it but there was
just like this one white line I was like
a little skunk face it was kind of like
it and so I started to darken it all up
and just even it up and it makes you
look you know like you know yeah yeah
yeah you could just draw I mean first of
all you could look eventually you could
just draw that on like a stencil where
you just kind of step into it and yeah I
just would never do the hair like that
you know I wouldn't do the like you know
stenciled hair line or even just you
know I do do a little makeup I you know
I'm wearing makeup now because you're on
TV and the whole thing because there's
just a quick question yes what do you
need makeup I've seen you on the lot you
you you're fantastic looking you look I
mean I need I get here at 6:00 in the
morning and all I have is makeup from
6:00 in the morning till we tape no they
apply layer upon layer of human flesh
tone I've seen you you look you look
this I don't know why you would always
be better man I'm Charlie I go to
Sephora and I was like I need that
little you know because you get a little
marks a little things I'm pushing my
wife out of the mirror I'm like I'm
sorry I need a little just color right a
little colors right right I'm interested
in have you you don't need this but I
need body makeup
I need makeup life I'm very interested
in any situation we have to take off my
shirt I'm very interested in like do
they make a makeup for guys like me
that gives me like a human chest it's
called a shirt and a suit that's you
just told me in a very polite way never
take
[Applause]
you